hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I have something to admit I like
fortnight save the world and sometimes I
play it instead of battle royale please
don't hate me but in all seriousness
fortnight save the world will benefit
battle royale players in fact here's 10
reasons why you BR players should give
save the world a chance
let's ultra quickly set the scene
fortnight save the world is a zombie
themed Survival title which predates the
battle royale mode which took over the
world in late 2017 as I'm writing this
it's only available in paid early access
but will eventually become free-to-play
let's cut straight to it v bucks the
number one reason to play save the world
it's those V books if you can't stop
spending v bucks on skins and pickaxes
or gliders then save the world is for
you
logging in every day will net you a
reward and one in seven of those will
drop V books usually a hundred and fifty
but I've had 800 v bucks dropped three
times in total even if you hate this
game mode by logging in each day you'll
make 600 v bucks a month and you already
have it installed on top of this our
daily challenges to complete and their
reward 50 or 60 B books - it's even
possible to be awarded B box for story
missions you can stack up to three daily
missions at once and these are
determined by a random task pool of
about twenty different things these have
recently been tweaked for example we
could be asked to destroy three fire
trucks or maybe the children see sauce
from the playgrounds and here's what
keeps the game fresh most maps are
randomly generated cleaning is sometimes
possible to find an abundance of items
altogether I regularly have a mission to
destroy gnomes or teddy bears and once
in a while I find their respective
stores and earn my v books in seconds if
one of those daily missions isn't your
liking for me and frickin hate sniping
zombies it's possible to switch that
mission out once every 24 hours then you
may receive another mission to slay
husks with a melee weapon instead other
dailies include building structures
rescuing survivors and using traps I
never know if I should admit this but at
present I earn 500 VBox a week which
means every month I can pick
a top-level battle royale skin without
spending any money in real life yes I am
a complete cheapskate so without a doubt
the greatest reason for a battle royale
player to play save the world is simply
because of those ebooks but be careful
you could become addicted to buying lute
Lamas instead and if you're lucky enough
you may find the upgraded silver Lama or
even the hallowed gold Lama building on
from this I'm sure you've noticed the
founders umbrella from the first day of
Battle Royale
the camo umbrella showed off that we
supported fortnight and epic before they
were making 100 million dollars a day it
felt great to support a developer I know
that's now a bit of a moot point seeing
their unprecedented success but back
then it was one of the only ways to
stand out from the crowd as I'm writing
this two new skins and two brand
spanking new backlinks have been added
to battle royale as a reward to those
people who have saved the world and it
feels pretty good to be called a founder
one of these skins is absolutely
gorgeous the roles leader okay I just
like pink a bit too much I'll be wearing
the skin with pride as a founder this
process is likely to continue with
further skins and cosmetic items only
available to save the world gamers as we
are in a locked system on console the
additional money we shell out on PS Plus
or games with gold will also net us
platform-specific skins like these on
PlayStation we can break down the other
benefits to playing save the world and a
great reason to play is the building
practice it offers again this point is a
little diminished after the permanent
inclusion of playgrounds in Battle
Royale but the build you can create in
save the world are designed to trap and
funneled zombies leading to your full
understanding of building integrity and
speed editing there's even a whole
community that attempts to out build
each other using their home storm shield
which is effectively a home based in the
game which perpetually consists so if
you log off it stays completely how you
left it the enemies in save the world
range from typical meandering zombies to
these fekus that from Bad bases with
explosives some use propane tanks to
blow through walls whilst others throw
zombies into your face to destroy it
from within your weapon skill and
building prowess will be 10
in save the world to follow on from
building let's look at gunplay without a
doubt fighting a horde of zombies will
improve your aim and decision-making
although they haven't learned to jump
around like headless chickens with
shotguns the zombies are aggressive and
relentless quickly hitting multiple
headshots is imperative at times and
this leads to understanding each weapon
type to a higher level practice peeking
around corners
finding the perfect sensitivity and
preparing for a Smasher to knock down
your entire structure can pressure you
to improve aim and decision-making
like I said hitting consecutive
headshots is a great boost to your
confidence and now build a pro is
supported in save the world the control
setup you're probably used to is here
the guns in battle royale can be crafted
in save the world but it's the plethora
of other options to be in or off laser
weapons sniper rifles with firework AoE
effects I even have a pistol from the
Chinese New Year limited time event
which follows my cursor after pressing
fire the range of weapons are insane and
regularly weapon types that are found
within save the world are introduced to
battle royale oh and there's also melee
weapons in save the world these feel
unbelievably great to use at some point
they must be introduced into battle
royale so now's a good time to know how
long it will take to swing a golf club
compared to a hunting axe
speaking of the limited time events just
like in Battle Royale save the world has
events that come and go these are for
extensions to the core story during the
blockbuster event on battle royale we
had a similar event that introduced a
mysterious new character to the world he
even had a backstory focused around the
loss of his wife in the zombie
apocalypse or husks as they're referred
to in save the world currently there's a
Western theme running through the PvE
which gives hints to future content or
battle royale oh and that meteor which
annihilated VR island
it hit save the world - and added levels
of law to the game which directly tie
into battle royale a weapon manufacturer
named vendor tech hold a key influence
in save the world and it's hinted that
they accidentally caused this storm
which brings down acid like rain and
attracts the undead the weapons we now
use to fight the storm are constructed
by the same company after the first
event wiped out the majority of the
world
98% I believe this annoying little robot
finds the core characters from battle
royale to increase defenses and find a
way to survive in this new world
contact our mission was to prevent this
storm from happening so and those
characters you know and love well they
actually have names like Ramirez and
they have voices - yeah back in action
we got a pack of us dead ahead
what's our firepower situation see for
yourself
[Music]
some even sing songs jam-packed with
film and TV references at this point I'm
tempted to break down the law in save
the world would anybody be interested in
hearing about that please let me know in
the comments moving on the skins in save
the world are some of the greatest you
will witness my current favorite is this
thick lid if you know a proper woman in
her bunny costume I also like the tail
definitely the tail I'm not looking at
anything else but seriously look at some
of these skins the Halloween event in
particular had absolutely great skins
and if this chaff ever makes it into
Battle Royale
I'll finally have a skin which looks
like me I just need it in pink now epic
please oh the skins just in that one
limited time event include Dracula a
mummy and Jason from Friday the 13th
plus the two we saw in Battle Royale
the skull trooper and the ghoul trooper
the skins in save the world relate to
different class types and different
skill sets they all have the same
abilities seen in Battle Royale
but the ninjas have an additional jump
the Constructors have a piece of kit to
strengthen structures the soldiers offer
more firepower and my class the
Outlanders can look around the world and
pick up these militarized mechanical
bears perfectly ridiculous another
reason to play save the world is this
beast a freaking hoverboard
okay I'll admit if anyone adds a
hoverboard to their game I have to buy
it
fortnight is already filled with Back to
the Future references but this one is
just jaw-dropping
it isn't needed in the slightest it's
sort of helps to maneuver around the map
but it's just another example of great
detail and a piece of fanservice which
improves the experience of fortnight and
finally the biggest reason for battle
royale players to try save the world
simple it's actually a good game when
he's given the chance teaming up with
friends to launch a rocket during a
zombie outbreak building your own
permanent storm shield over weeks and
months and above all playing a game
which is so full of content it did take
months to fully understand but for now
just plate like a battle royale zombie
mode once it grabs you your wonder why
it wasn't in your game collection last
year
to summarize three V books practicing
buildings and weapon drills trying out
new gun types and modifications
experiencing more from the limited time
events and the potential the law has to
offer
seeing those character designs using a
freaking hoverboard and above all taking
on the zombie hordes fortnight save the
world has more to offer than you think
I'm Adam from Playstation grenades and
this comes up quite a lot so I'll answer
it now I am not sponsored by anyone I am
not told what to do by PlayStation or
Sony I'm completely independent any
products that I look at our because I
want to this is simply an old games
design teacher giving his opinion anyway
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]